[Musik]
philipp benjamin wird ein jahr alt
eine leihmutter brachte ihn in den usa
auf die welt das kann man so gar nicht
in worte fassen das ganze glück was an
da wieder so widerfahren ist das letzte
jahr und es war einfach unbeschreiblich
ein stückweit sehr glücklich sind wir
letzten endes dem schließe ich mich an
es ist wirklich so dass schon seit den
letzten drei vier tagen geht man immer
wieder so die ganzen geschichten durch
was man so alles erlebt hat und und es
ist verrückt dass ein jahr rum ist für
stefan und victory mann schien der
wunsch ein eigenes kind zu haben lange
zeit wie ein unerreichbarer traum also
für mich würde es auch anderen wirklich
real als auf die welt gekommen ist ich
war ja noch in deutschland gestellt da
drüben war bei der geburt dabei und da
war das wie ein schlag also ich hab es
war der nacht ruhig die info bekommen
habe geschrien geheult und wo ich dachte
irgendwas passiert und sagen die hier
irgendwas mit aktiviert so und diese
vaterschaft instinkt aber dass also der
moment wo ich wirklich dachte da ist was
grundlegendes und einem passiert dieser
satz
das hat sich jetzt auch negativ an wer
keine kinder hat kann es nicht
nachvollziehen aber dieser satz stimmt
einfach
in dem moment passiert so vieles mit
einem unter ich kann es nicht
beschreiben was ich bin dankbar dass das
alles so funktioniert hat und das wie
ein gesundes kind haben der so fröhlich
ist
für dieses glück mussten die eltern ins
ausland gehen die leihmutterschaft ist
in deutschland verboten
eine amerikanische agentur hat ihnen
geholfen die passende leihmutter in den
usa zu finden einfach war das ganze
nicht
es war auch das problem das wir damals
auf platz nun mal 52 oder 53 waren- und
die agentur nur 1 bis 2 leihmütter
vermittelt pro monat was heißt die
sieben sehr sehr aus also die müssen
psychologische tests machen sie haben 90
prozent ich lerne jetzt mal
durchfallquote die für eine
leihmutterschaft nicht geeignet sind
weil letzten endes fels auf die
agenturen auf den anwalt zurück wenn die
leihmutter sagten dass kind das ich
gewonnen habe ist meint das blatt in den
usa leihmutter denn aus minnesota
überzeugte sowohl die agentur als auch
die 1 es war eine spontane entscheidung
einfach war die sympathie da war und
auch dass die leihmutter das schon mal
gemacht hat waren grund und sie hatten
auch in deutschland besucht gehabt ein
wochenende und es war einfach schon fast
familiär wir haben jetzt auch immer noch
kontakt mit ihr das ist im prinzip so
wie jetzt die tante von dem philipp
stufen wir das mal rein und haben
regelmäßig kontakt über whatsapp und
jetzt auch über skype und wie schwer
fiel den beiden die entscheidung wer
biologischer vater von philipp wird
ja das war schon geklärt weil ich eben
schon sechs neffen und nichten hab da
ist er meine genetik schon verbreitet
genug worden weil mir was ich habe eine
schwester sie hatte ein wunderbares kind
aber sich dann auch entschieden bei dem
ein kind bleibt und da haben wir gesagt
okay wäre schön wenn ich dann noch so
ein bisschen meine genetik weitergeben
das muss man auch noch kurz erwähnen die
genetische mutter von unserem kind dass
es eine eizellenspende und nachdem wir
beide alles abgegeben haben konnten dann
die embryo nicht nenne es jetzt mal um
technisch gezüchtet werden
neun monate später war es dann soweit
stefan einmal reißt zehn tage vor der
geburt in die usa um dabei zu sein und
natürlich das kind abzuholen
das ist nicht zu beschreiben das stolz
ist so ein schalter der umswitchen dem
auf einmal mein mann ist dann wirklich
vater und hält es in seinen arm und es
ist ein wahnsinniges gefühl wir haben
auch eine sehr lecker rechtsanwältin
gehabt die auch so sehr guten kontakt
zur leihmutter hatte die auch die
leihmutter kannte die leihmutter war ja
schon mal leihmutter für
niederländisches pärchen hat zwillinge
ausgetragen das heißt sie hat das
prozedere schon bekannt und von daher
war das wirklich eher so ein familiäres
verhältnis aber natürlich ich will es
aus dem leben formulieren
sie hat geweint wie schloss und sie muss
letzten endes der richterin sagen ich
möchte dieses kind nicht sie ist
rechtliche mutter sie hat es geboren
ich möchte es nicht ich möchte dass der
genetische vater das bin ich das kind
aufzieht groß werden lässt und
unverzüglich aus minnesota wirklich mit
nach europa geht an philips ersten
geburtstag sprechen sie mal wieder mit
der leihmutter
denn ist 35 jahre alt hat selbst zwei
eigene kinder
wir nutzen die chance sie besser kennen
zu lernen was geht ihr durch den kopf
wenn sie den kleinen so sieht ich werde
philipp immer lügen ich habe ihn ja in
mir getragen aber ich habe keine gefühle
für ihn wie ich sie für meine eigenen
kinder habe selbst als er geboren wurde
er auf er lag es war nicht dasselbe
gefühl lieber meinen eigenen kindern als
ich ihnen den armen seines vaters
gesehen habe wurde ich emotional da hab
ich gesehen ich habe ihnen geholfen eine
familie zu werden als leihmutter hat
denn für ein anderes paar schon
zwillinge auf die welt gebracht und
jetzt plant sie schon die nächste
leihmutterschaft erzählt sie wird das so
gut bezahlt oder warum tut sie sich das
an
es geht mir nicht nur um geld das geld
ist definitiv von vorteil
aber wie geht es darum menschen zu
helfen die nicht in der lage
sie sind selbst kinder zu gebären ich
bin schon immer eine könnerin gewesen
habe schon immer anderen geholfen es
geht nicht ums geld es geht mir darum
meiner familie zu helfen vollständig zu
werden und dann möchte ich gerne wissen
warum sie geweint hat als sie vor
gericht bestätigen musste dass philipp
nicht ihr kind ist ich bin eine sehr
emotionale frau ich meine manchmal
aufgrund von einfachen dingen
die leute fragen mich schon warum weinst
du denn das sind freudentränen es war
überwältigend zu sehen dass diese
familie nun vollständig ist sie können
legal ihr kind mit nach hause nehmen
wie schafft das eine frau die ein kind
neun monate in sich trägt es auf die
welt bringt keine emotionale bindung zum
baby aufzubauen
scheinbar schaffen es viele leihmütter
aber wie glaubwürdig ist dass das fragen
wir den medizin ethiker giovanni maio er
lehrt am institut für ethik und
geschichte der medizin in freiburg und
beschäftigt sich mit ethischen fragen
der reproduktionsmedizin
das ist sehr glaubwürdig viele studien
belegen genau das dass die leihmütter im
wissen darum dass es gar nicht ihr kind
sein
obwohl sie das kind gebären werden im
wissen darum schalten sie quasi eine
distanzierung vor einer die leihmütter
distanzieren sich von dem kind sie
spalten quasi das kind von ihrem leib ab
das kind ist zwar im eigenen leib aber
die leihmütter distanzieren sich von dem
kind als die formalitäten in den usa
geklärt waren ist stefan einmal mit dem
baby sieben wochen nach philips geburt
heimgekommen am flughafen zu landen war
ein schönes gefühl
es war eine kleine odyssee nach
deutschland letzten endes zukommt aber
es hat beim zoll sage ich mal jetzt dann
schon fragen aufgeworfen wobei die sehr
nett waren und so viele jetzt nicht
unbedingt halten
das hat mich auch noch mehr aufhorchen
lassen dass es doch so fremd ist aber
den sachverhalt verstanden haben haben
gesagt okay es gibt keine mutter es gibt
zwei vätern der eine vater hat
zugestimmt dass ich jetzt hier mit dem
kind einreisen darf
und dann haben wir die grenze
überschritten waren zu hause
der traum vom eigenen kind hatte für die
einst einen hohen preis mehr als 100.000
euro mit allem drum und dran agentur und
anwaltskosten die leihmutter musste
bezahlt werden
reise aufenthalts und krankenhauskosten
das paar hat für ihr projekt kind lange
gespart und sie würden es
weiterempfehlen
wenn sie natürlich kinder wollen können
auf jeden fall
es ist kein leichter weg definitiv nicht
aber das resultat ist unbezahlbar halt
und unterstützung haben sie während
dieser zeit vor allem von ihren
familienmitgliedern erfahren ihre ehe
hat sich dadurch verändert
man lernt seinen partner neu zu schätzen
weil man einfach eine größere aufgabe
bewältigt und das resultat sieht dass
das ein wunderbares kind ist das jetzt
heute an diesem tag ein jahr alt wird
und mehr zusammenhalt und gemeinsame
aufgabe kann man sich gar nicht
vorstellen
also das hat der beziehung noch mal ganz
anderen auftritt gegeben
definitiv ja
philipp benjamin wird eines tages viele
fragen haben sein vater stefan heimann
ist der biologische vater die genetische
mutter ist eine amerikanische eizellen
spenderin denn die leihmutter hat ihren
körper zur verfügung gestellt und
philipp auf die welt zu bringen
das kind hat eine komplizierte
herkunftsgeschichte das soll aber nicht
heißen dass philipp deswegen ein
unglücklicher junge werden muss was wir
nicht tun dürfen ist anzunehmen dass das
glück des kindes allein von den genen
abhängt und allein von der genetischen
abstammung von den eltern wir müssen
anerkennen dass die soziale elternschaft
etwas sehr wichtiges ist und dass das
glück der kinder am ende doch mehr davon
abhängen in welchem umfeld ist dann
leben kann ob es von den eltern die
soziale eltern dann sind angenommen wird
ob es geliebt wird ob das kind sich in
diesen in dieser umgebung geborgen für
davon hängt das glück des kindes ab in
vielen ländern ist die leihmutterschaft
erlaubt es gibt unterschiedliche modelle
wie die kommerzielle leihmutterschaft in
teilen der usa in der ukraine indien
oder russland
dann gibt es das altruistische modell
da erhält die frau kein geld wie etwa in
kanada dänemark oder australien
die leihmutterschaft darf nicht komplett
dem freien markt überlassen werden warnt
giovanni maio dann haben wir schon die
gefahr dass die leihmütter ausgebeutet
werden und dass die kinder im grunde zu
häuslichen objekt degradiert werden
nicht dass man ein kind bestellt gegen
geld und das dann ab und wie man das
bestellt hat das muss man vermeiden also
einerseits dass die leihmütter selber
als subjekte wahrgenommen werden die
eben nicht verteidigt werden dürfen
die eben nicht benutzt werden dürfen die
immer noch quasi als subjekte
entscheiden können müssen wenn ich das
kind wirklich abgeben oder möchte ich es
behalten und die kinder selber die
geboren werden die müssen natürlich in
einer weise auf die welt kommen können
das vollkommen klar ist zu wem sie
gehören
und dass die rechte dieser kinder
gewahrt werden
vor allem das recht darauf zu wissen von
wem sie genetisch abstand und man sich
dahingehend bewusst dass es durchaus
auch ein stückweit konfliktpotenziale
geben wird also ist es nicht alles ganz
toll wir werden auch gewisse
konfliktsituation haben und bin ich
davon überzeugt victor ist bei uns ein
bisschen der ruhepol dass wir das
gemeinsam gut vermitteln können er wird
wissen welche frau hat mich auf die welt
gebracht aber er hat keine genetische
bindung zu der frau dass wir da hängt
man ja auch verstehen
familie reimann hat sich für die usa
entschieden weil die leihmutterschaft im
bundesstaat minnesota gesetzlich
geregelt ist das hat ihnen sicherheit
gegeben sie haben fünf jahre an ihrem
traum gearbeitet
warum zahlen menschen so einen hohen
preis für ein kind das leben es doch
auch ohne kinder lebenswert oder das
lebensprojekt kinder zu haben ist nun
mal eines das wir nicht bewerten dürfen
und in sofern der staat nicht einfach
restriktionen ohne gründe vornehmen kann
das heißt also wenn ein paar kinder
haben möchte muss der staat durchaus die
möglichkeiten eröffnen diesen part zu
helfen aber nicht um jeden preis
das ist der der vernünftigen damit wir
dürfen gegen solche projekte nicht
bewerten wir dürfen nicht sagen so ein
leben ist richtig und erstrebenswert und
anderes nicht genauso wie wenn paare
sagen was sie kennen die kinder haben
wollen dürfen das nicht bewerten möchte
das ist eben eine ganz individuelle
entscheidung und in einer liberalen
gesellschaft mischen wir uns sehen
solche entscheidungen nicht ein
der kleine philipp benjamin hat einen
amerikanischen pass
jetzt warten seine eltern auf die
deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
das verfahren dauert noch an
[Musik]